the music of Draco the ruler whose real
name is Darrell Caldwell details life in
South Los Angeles with lyrics that are
graphic violent and clever oh my just
lows of where you find it is deadly town
and a real by 2018 he was on his way to
becoming part of la's rap elite
according to Los Angeles Times following
in the paths of artists like dr. Dre
Snoop Dogg and NWA but Caldwell was
arrested on murder charges in his trial
his lyrics and videos were used as
evidence against him prosecutors allege
the Caldwell was a part of a botched
plot to kill a rival at a party he
attended in December 2016 allegedly in
the midst of a shootout he and his gang
had accidentally murdered 24 year old
Davi on Gregory prosecutors said
Caldwell rapped about his crimes around
town with a tommy gun and a Jag and you
can disappoint the other narcotic
prosecutors are becoming even bolder in
their attempts to use these laws taking
cases to ridiculous extremes Draco's is
one example Eric Nielsen a liberal arts
professor at the University of Richmond
is the co-author of rap on trial a book
chronicling the growing use of rap
lyrics and criminal proceedings the jury
in Caldwell's trial rejected the
prosecution's theory he was convicted on
just one count illegal gun possession
separate charges of criminal gang
conspiracy and shooting from a vehicle
resulted in a hung jury so prosecutors
opted to retry him on the remaining
charges allegedly as a member of the
gang implicated by the prosecution Coble
had benefited from Gregory's murder
which under California's Penal Code
means he could be sentenced to life in
prison
Coble is currently in the Los Angeles
County men's Central Jail awaiting trial
we don't know what's gonna happen in the
trial we don't know if the lyrics and
the videos like come into play but they
did last time they did last time
fairly extensively and I suspect that
they will again I think many people have
find it difficult to imagine that these
young men are doing something complex
sophisticated that could be considered
literary artistic it's much easier to
say oh they're just rapping about their
lives and that's precisely why
prosecutors are bringing it in I
many of them understand that they are
misrepresenting rap lyrics they know
that they're doing that they're doing it
because they want the jury to see this
stuff that is yep
salacious it's profane and therefore
you're compromising somebody's right to
a fair trial Nielsen says the
prosecutors who take rap lyrics
literally don't understand the art form
which first emerged in New York City's
South Bronx to the 1970s South Bronx a
national symbol for urban decay street
gangs really reigned supreme in the
South Bronx and there were hundreds of
fighting street gangs across New York
City and so what you saw with hip hop
was that it really was at least for some
of the early founders of the movement
it really was seen as a productive and
creative alternative to gang life it
drew on the territoriality of gang life
it drew on that inherent competitiveness
of it but it was a way to take something
that was destructive and turned it into
something productive something artistic
rappers created fictionalized versions
of themselves influenced by
blaxploitation films and the work of
pimp turned author iceberg slim gangster
rap didn't start garnering massive
mainstream appeal until 1991 when
billboard changed its methodology for
calculating its famous music rankings
instead of calling record store managers
and taking them at their word about what
was selling the company started counting
the barcode sales of transactions
gangster rap catapulted to the top of
the charts and record companies took
notice that still is seen by many as the
formula for success in rap music that's
not to say there aren't exceptions there
are the Will Smith's and the MC Hammer's
and whatever else but generally speaking
especially with amateurs they see the
sort of gangster rap model where
regional variations of gangsta rap they
see that as the pathway to success
because they have many models where that
has been true yes it's it's hyperbolic
it's over the top and it not only
embraces stereotypes about young black
men it doubles down on them it's a AIT's
the criminality intentionally it doubles
down on the violence it doubles down on
the hyper sexuality so it's a form that
is very aware of the stereotypes that
many people hold about young black men
and it revels in them and sort of flips
them on their head and that's what's so
interesting about it is that it's taken
something very negative and turned it
into its own art form when did you start
seeing it in criminal proceedings
you had these early cases in the 1990s
that sort of laid the foundation for
this practice and then what happened is
that prosecutors started targeting these
lyrics more explicitly you had training
manuals one of the ones that we cite in
the book is actually from Allen Jackson
who was a former prosecutor in Los
Angeles that encourages police and
prosecutors to look for lyrical evidence
in order to portray somebody as a thug
or a gangster and so word started to
spread and professionally prosecutors
are talking to each other the same way
that defense attorneys do and what they
saw was that it became successful not
only in that it could secure convictions
when you didn't have much evidence but
also that you were not likely to get
overturned on appeal and so it started
to solidify Nielsen says that another
turning point came around 2008 with the
rise of social media we see a lot more
cases that's largely because there's far
more material out there now right if you
want to get disseminate your music now
you don't need a record label you don't
need the radio you don't need anything
you can go directly using you know
YouTube or SoundCloud very low barriers
to entry and so you saw a proliferation
of this music out there in videos that
have become increasingly easy to produce
right you can make professional-looking
videos with a phone now with the sort of
proliferation of these videos and songs
all across the internet you saw also a
proliferation of the policing of those
songs
Nielsen's legal testimony and writings
about the misuse of rap and criminal
proceedings have brought more attention
to the issue in March 2019 he partnered
with Grammy award-winning rapper killer
Mike in filing an amicus brief with the
US Supreme Court and defensive a
Pittsburgh rapper named Jamal Knox sent
to prison for making terroristic threats
to police officers in a song the High
Court declined to hear the case but Knox
having served his time still has that
terroristic threat conviction on his
record which could affect him for the
rest of his life so killer Mike is
someone who wrote a foreword for your
book can you read just the highlighted
in here all right right now aspiring rap
artists need to know they are being
targeted by the authorities and they
need to balance their right to free
speech and their desire to push the
envelope of free speech with the reality
that police are watching cobbles trial
is expected to begin in early 2020 and
it's possible prosecutors will use his
lyrics and videos again cobbles time in
jail has been difficult he spent time in
solitary confinement and at least at one
point thought about giving up music
altogether are we in the midst of a
chilling effect on an art form it's very
hard to measure a chilling effect
because a chilling effect is essentially
you are creating the conditions where
people are no longer producing things
are less likely to produce things so
it's tough to measure the absence of
something but I do see this as
potentially chilling especially as
prosecutors become bolder in the ways
and strategies that they're using to put
artists rap artists in jail I do think
that we are reaching a point at which
many people are going to have to weigh
their desire to engage in this art form
you know to master this art form they're
gonna have to weigh that with the
reality that it could get them in
trouble as these cases continue to grow
in number I do think that that is that
is absolutely possible I know I think I
sound cold but if you walk up and I'll
show you understand that is way
[Music]
Just Dance
[Music]